tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo tanto mi
sono avvicinato a dio mio ed oggi siamo
tornati su the forest ci vediamo su the
forest
vi lascio il video mi avrebbe dovuto
prendere fuoco
in realtà non ha funzionato scusate non
era quello l'intento va beh qualche
[ __ ] quanto 6 grosso la madonna che
volta è morto ucciso mica quanti ne ho
fatti fuori regali 200 non fatti fuori
ciao zio ma grazie malanni mi servirebbe
quella roba che c'è in testa sai no
adesso non me ne vado finché non mi dai
la torcia che hai
ho visto ho visto che ce l'hai tanto la
doccia nude che fai finta di niente
ammazzato un piccione anche tu che ti
metti in mezzo sei scemo ma vorrei a non
importa la [ __ ] importante essere
sopravvissuto basta è mio
datevi a piccioni della minkia c'è un
altro passerà davanti così faccio fuori
tutte le tutti quanti sì però ti devi
calmare ti devi calmare ai presenti alla
camomilla usa lazio usa la odio chi
cazzo è plasmato fuoco
burqa merda si picchiano si picchiano
che culo bravi bravi
botte botte botte no che cazzo vedi sta
picchiando lui niente si sono
riappacificati che sfiga perché dovete
evitare gli schiaffi continuate no
finita quello che avete iniziato bra
scappa bravo bravo e tu che cazzo è
bravo scappa musiche di morire e tu chi
è tornato
non pensavo più scorsa della gamba dove
hai messo temi brutto bastardo lei
rapito io lo so l'avrà hanno portato
qualche parte quel bambino non so dove
però trovato una cascata bellissima se
non fosse l'una di notte che ti posto
passando la notte fuori cioè scusami e
di tanto carino ti giuro non volevo
ucciderti però devo mangiare anche io
tutto l'episodio che non vedono ma se ne
avesse preso la torcia maledizione sarei
a posto a quest ora hai freddo crea un
fuoco per riscatto
si vede che sto preparando e che avevo
trovato il fuoco decente mi dispiace
perché sto arrivando
lontanissimo ragazzi io comunque mi sto
facendo i chilometri non perché sono
pazzo ma perché sto cercando d'altra
parte dell'aereo no ve lo dico che sono
veramente sembra un pazzoide la smetti
di cosa che mi mette ansia
dov'è la casa mia casa mia e dalla parte
opposta del pianeta proprio allora
facciamo sto fuoco forse riesco a farmi
anche l'accampamento siamo a postissimo
ok ce l'ho fatta ragazzi mi sono fatto
rifugio so anche magnate o tutto magna
qualcos'altro che che mio dio ci hai
sempre fame madonna incredibile sto
mangiai più di qualsiasi persona al
mondo
in realtà mi sono fatto rifugio quando è
uscito al mattino c'è la precisione
incredibile però aver fantastico ragazzi
non ci credo che ci sto riuscendo in una
maniera incredibile dai famo che dormire
almeno recupera un po di sonno non so
cosa mi serva visto che lui è a julia è
bello cammina così almeno intrattieni da
solo mentre c'è tutta sta a noi è
incredibile quante che sto sopravvivendo
il suo posto de merda three days quasi 4
il che è un record mondiale incredibile
mai sopravvissuto un giorno
in croce ma ragazzi era così grosso sta
mappa anche l'altra volta perché mi
piace mi stavo ammazzando in una maniera
che non potete capire piano molto piano
molto piano bravissimo altro po arrivo
in sardegna c'è veramente da sei
credibile sbandando non so neanche più
io dove dio veramente ma dai c'era neve
sul serio che figo 9 bellissimo non
pensavo ci fosse ritrovarne venzo gioco
hanno fatto un nuovo bioma efficacia
potevo farlo nella neve la casa mica che
figo tipo minecraft seriamente ha già
finita aveva posto finito di un metro e
mezzo di neve poi è tutto come prima
almeno un quel metro e mezzo che lo so
goduto devo dire la verità sono luana un
cinghiale che pensavo fossero lupi mi
stavo pagando in mano a non correre giro
tanto non lo prenderò mai lo so già
fatto che c'è una fame che sto crepando
però non è quello che tanto non c'ho
voglia di inseguire animali di stato in
culo o vengono e si fanno uccidere o non
vado a prenderli io sono bear grylls e
stasera vi si vi spiegherò come
sopravvivere con gli scoiattoli parte 1
uccidete lo scoiattolo parte ii prendete
la testa e giocate cia calcio oppure da
te la bambina e cile non trovo l'aereo
ragazzi cio fame ciò freddo sto morendo
potrebbe andar peggio però potrebbe
piovere ma la vera questa cosa sapevo lo
sapevo che non dovevo dirlo però perché
mi piaceva
c'è una torcia per terra non è per terra
ce l'hanno già lande le persone c'è un
ponte qui che figo io passo è stronzi
top ma tra l'altro a barisciano gli
snack mi chiama punto mangiali snack che
pirla
ragazzi ma voi avete una minima idea da
quanto io mi sto muovendo ci domanda
quante ore sto correndo cos'è 6 freddo
zio e va beh non posso farlo il fuoco
non c'ho le robe
non so le robe o tartaruga dami prestami
il guscio che che sto crepando di freddo
prova a fare fuoco che ti devo dire
proviamoci prove non è colpa mia
sto a posto ma solo col fuoco non mi
rompere le palle se ne va bene ma nasce
una roba strana che devo assolutamente
andare a vedere muoviti a bruciare che
devo magna con la a e la casa addosso
fuori non è vero non sono fuori sono qui
allora senti io non ti disturbo non ti
disturbo vado via vado via vado via vado
vado via vado via dove però io voglio
attraverso l'aereo ti giuro non mi serve
di romperti le palle con la torcia di
che cazzo sei delle big che cosa è un
coccodrillo quello veramente ci sono i
coccodrilli quando ci sono due
coccodrilli è un orangotango due piccoli
e non ci credono a ostia 3 [ __ ] light
bar di crepare seeds io però non è un
rave party questo è fatevi i cazzi
vostri che il morite sempre poi vi
lamentate aiutato il ceo salute ok
ragazzi devo provare a fare una cosa
scusatemi se tu sono così impulsivo
devo provarci sul serio allora questo
più tagliafuoco dalle foto perfetto
adesso te la posso lanciare facendo
danni seri non come prima di equa frate
la sorella 2 in 1 anno 1 solo a vai dai
già qualcosa
mi dispiace zio quanto mi dispiace che
tradotto un ente guarda lì non ti
incazzare l'ho fatto per amicizia è un
modo mio modo per dirti che mi piace
smettila di lamentarti deficiente se ne
sono scappati tutti gola colato con la
molotov non c'è più nessuno ebbe grazie
a dio almeno quello migliaia che gli ho
dato fuoco ragazzi cè un precipizio
pazzesco pro forse gli scopi non ci
riesco a passare dio mio sono quasi
morto non scherzavo scherzavo di brutto
non lo faccio più sto scherzando sono
arrivato esattamente al limite della
mappa c'è più niente qua veramente ho
fatto dei chilometri non sono anche b
dove casa mia al chiodo ragazzuoli
conclude che presa sexy ho fatto con
quello che l'episodio sporche video vi
sia piaciuto e cosa e cosa vi è piaciuto
al momento è morto il telecomando è
stato commentato mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e cavani lo trovate
nella descrizione io arrivo dalla
descrizione perché ho fatto così se
avresti discrete riciclavano fossero
vinto quello ragazzi